all right I am seriously psyched to do
this interview right now I have truly
one of my heroes from wrestling back in
the 80s to movies to politics and now a
guy that I truly truly admire and he's
off the grid which is why I'm wearing
these crazy headphones and we're doing
this on some super crazy high tech
connection governor Jesse Ventura how
are you sir
Dave I'm doing terrific how are you
doing I am doing well I cannot begin to
tell you the technical hurdles that we
had to jump through to make this happen
but that is the proof that you truly are
off the grid so can you tell us a little
bit about that just first off well I'm
uh I'm off the grid I decided to do this
right after I left office as governor
because I was young enough to go on an
adventure and I decided to do it and so
we ventured down here way down south of
the border about a thousand miles and I
bought a home that I'm an hour from
pavement and an hour from electricity
and I've been living down here now
off and on for going on eight years and
now that I have this show I may be down
here permanently with not returning to
the United States soon because I love it
down you're off the grid I love the
people where I live and it's now the
creation of my show
broadcasting back into America as
opposed to looking at America from the
outside looking in
as opposed the inside looking out yes so
why does someone who has commercial
success as an actor and a wrestler and
then who has political success
staggering political success actually
why do you feel that you had to go off
the grid well I didn't feel I have to
but I just felt I wanted an adventure I
was turning at the time I was just gone
over 50 and your window of opportunity
in time it got to the point Dave I'll
give it to your blunt yeah when you get
to my age at about 60 years old 62 I am
now time becomes more important than
money and so that was the reason I did
it I wanted to go on the adventure and
it has been that and now I it's paid off
because I have the show off the grid and
you know we're in a situation right now
where if you criticize the US government
they might
kill you with a drone because they don't
well they don't have to take you to
court anymore they don't have to charge
you with a crime they don't have to go
through due process at all they can just
shoot you and kill you with a drone if
you come become a problem so we got to
keep moving down here off the grid to
stay away from those drones right so
this is the stuff that we talk about all
the time over here but you're actually
living if you actually felt that I guess
you have enough influence or your voice
is powerful enough that you actually
felt I assume some sort of threat either
not maybe not spoken but just sort of
unspoken is that fair to say oh no I
never got threatened but I was I was
being blackballed out there the last
book tour the last book tour I did none
of the networks NBC CBS or ABC would
have me on Fox won't have me on MSNBC
won't have me on CNN has me on
occasionally so this presented an
opportunity what happened I was doing a
book tour and I saw in my schedule Larry
King and I thought wait a minute Larry
retired what's this and I walked into a
hotel in New York and there was Larry
King yeah Larry said I'm on he said I'm
on aura dot TV this is where you need to
be and so we started discussing it and I
explained to them I said well there's a
problem I live off the grid for four to
five months a year how could I possibly
do a show for you and they said that's
not a problem we have state-of-the-art
technology they said as long as we got
energy and as we get a clear shot at the
satellite we can do your show from
anywhere in the world and so that's how
often and then off the grid became the
show we thought then let's make that the
show that we're off the grid
broadcasting back to the United States
much the same I don't know if you're old
enough to remember but when Wolfman Jack
first hit the famous shock jock dis jock
way before Howard Stern the mystique
about the Wolfman with all the teenage
kids I remember it was that that they
wouldn't let the Wolfman broadcast from
the United States so he had the
broadcast from Mexico into the United
States and that's what we all believed
as teenagers about the Wolfman so I'm
just kind of you
the ol Wolfman Jack thing here I'm going
outside the country for real and
broadcasting back in all right well so
let's talk about that though the heart
of why you're outside of the country I
mean I think you see this this country
much the way I see it it's it's a
country that you love and you want to be
better but seems really broken right now
right totally I blame the Democrats and
Republicans both of them equally as bad
as each other they are the problem they
are not the solution they have been in
charge for a hundred and fifty years now
look at the shape we're in I just saw
statistically Dave the other day a baby
born when it takes its first breath of
air in the United States on birth is
$50,000 in debt 50 grand in debt when
you take your first breath air who's
responsible for this the Democrats and
Republicans they've been in charge for
150 years they've destroyed our country
and we've got to take it back from him
yeah so speaking of taking it back so
you were someone that you started taking
it back because you as an independent at
the time became governor of Minnesota
which in retrospect does that almost
seem crazy to you that that actually
worked because now it almost seems like
we could never have an independent not
true at all not I prove that it does
work and we only raised $300,000 Dave
yeah 98 to elect me governor 300 gram I
actually made more money being governor
than what I spent to get it I don't
think there's another elected official
nationally who can make that statement
in 50 years yeah that they made more
money doing the job than what they spent
to get it no it could happen I'll tell
you right now
I'll make you bold here we are on Dave's
program I'll give you a bold prediction
that if I could if I could get ballot
access in all 50 states and if I were
guaranteed to be allowed in the debates
I would be your next president in 2016